Ein genialer,
aber schwer kranker Wissenschaftler.
Brauchen Sie einen Arzt?
Ich bin Arzt.
Um sich selbst zu heilen,
wagt er ein Experiment.
*Er schreit.*
Danach ist er geheilt
und hat übermenschliche Fähigkeiten.
Aber das hat seinen Preis.
Da ist etwas in mir,
das will jagen
und verlangt nach Blut.
Tag, zusammen!
Mit "Morbius" verbindet Sony
verschiedene "Spider-Man"-Universen
und holt mir Jared Leto
als Hauptdarsteller
einen DC-Charakter
rüber zu Marvel.
Er ist in beiden
Comicfilm-Universen zu Hause.
Das ist großartig.
Jetzt sprechen wir auf diesem Kanal
nach den Zombies auch über Vampire.
Wie haut das denn hin
mit dem ganzen Bluttrinken?
Dafür sprechen wir mit dem
Kriminal-Biologen unseres Vertrauens:
Dr. Mark Benecke.
Mark kennt sich mit den Toten aus,
ist Präsident der transsylvanischen
Dracula-Gesellschaft
und er hat mehrere Bücher
über Real-Life-Vampire geschrieben.
Das sind Menschen,
die sich als lebende Vampire fühlen
und Blut trinken.
Marc, willkommen zurück
bei "Science vs. Fiction".
Es ist wirklich geil hier.
Und es hallt auch.
Hallo.
Vor den Real-Life-Vampiren
bleiben wir erstmal bei "Morbius".
Der wurde
durch ein Experiment zum Vampir,
mit Vampir-Fledermäusen.
Er wird hinterher stärker, schneller,
hat eine Art Radar und kann fliegen.
Das hat aber einen Nachteil:
Er hat plötzlich Bock auf Blut.
Das kennt man von Vampiren,
aber Morbius
ist durch Wissenschaft entstanden.
Er ist ein lebendiger Vampir.
Da können wir dich einbeziehen
und das mal biologisch betrachten.
Was müsste sich im Körper verändern,
damit er Blut trinken kann?
Der gesamte Stoffwechsel
müsste sich verändern,
weil Menschen
sonst andere Dinge essen.
Blut ist eine Art dünne Limonade,
die ein bisschen Eiweiß enthält.
Aber das, was wir sonst brauchen,
Zucker, Vitamine, usw., das fehlt.
Man kann keine schnelle Energie
daraus ziehen.
Der ganze Körper
müsste sich verändern,
sonst würde er
an Energiemangel sterben.
Es gibt Tiere, die das machen.
Es gibt Vampir-Finken
und Vampir-Fledermäuse, wie im Film.
Was ist bei denen anders?
In einer Studie, die man zu den
Tieren gemacht hat, entdeckte man
dass Vampir-Fledermäuse springende
Anteile in der Erbsubstanz haben.
Das sind kleine Stückchen,
die heißen Transposon.
Für deren Entdeckung
gab es einen Nobelpreis.
Transposon sorgen dafür,
dass sich das Erbgut
schneller mischen kann.
Man kann sich an Veränderungen,
andere Lebensräume besser anpassen.
Wenn man Blut trinkt,
nimmt man z.B. auch Viren mit auf.
D.h. Stoffwechsel-Veränderung
und Veränderungen der Erbsubstanz
durch die springenden Anteile.
So ist es
bei echten Vampir-Fledermäusen.
D.h., er müsste die Teile
von dem Genom übernommen haben
oder selbst schon springende Teile
im Genom gehabt haben.
Das könnte ganz viel sein.
Er könnte selbst Teile
der springenden Erbsubstanz haben,
die jetzt geboostert sind
und mehr springen.
Das ist biologisch möglich.
Es könnte sein, dass sich
die Erbsubstanz umgebaut hat.
Oder es wurde übernommen
durch etwas, das er eingenommen hat.
Durch Strahlung
würde das auch gehen.
Das müsste dann aber alle
seine Körperzellen betreffen, oder?
Auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt zwar
auch in der Natur mal Schimären,
d.h. verschiedene Sorten Zellen
in einem Körper.
Aber der Großteil der Zellen
müsste davon betroffen sein.
Das ist sehr schwierig,
aber Film eben möglich.
Das stimmt.
Wir haben das auch schon besprochen
in unserer Folge zur Radioaktivität.
Da geht es um Superhelden,
deren Zellen
durch Strahlung verändert werden.
Wenn das aber
nicht so realistisch ist, Mark,
könnte er noch Sachen von
den Fledermäusen übernommen haben?
Ja, die Bakterien im Körper.
Im Darm und auf Haut haben wir
mehr Bakterien als Zellen im Körper.
Bei der Fledermaus
sind es Fledermauszellen.
Diese vielen Bakterienzellen
müssten angepasst sein
auf diese Blutmahlzeiten.
Bei Vampir-Fledermäusen
können die Bakterien
Vitamine, Eiweiße,
Zucker aus dem Blut
so herstellen,
dass sie verfügbar werden.
Blut ist, wie gesagt,
eine dünne Limonade.
Diese Bakterien-Umstellung
ließe sich wohl leichter machen,
indem derjenige die Bakterien isst
und der Körper sich drauf einstellt.
D.h., Morbius müsste entweder
sein ganzes Genmaterial anpassen
oder mindestens
diese Bakterien übernehmen.
Oder beides.
Das ist natürlich schwierig.
Denn viele von diesen Bakterien,
die Vampir-Fledermäuse haben,
würden uns und Morbius
vielleicht auch krank machen.
Es ist ein dickes Brett,
das er da bohren muss.
Was haben Sie gemacht, Doktor?
Ich wünschte, ich wüsste es.
Der Film findet eine Lösung dafür.
Wir bleiben mal
beim Fledermaus-Vergleich.
Wie viel Blut müsste Morbius trinken?
Diese Fledermäuse
sind leicht, wiegen nur 50 g.
Sie trinken alle 3 Tage
ca. die Hälfte ihres Körpergewichts.
Du kannst mal rechnen.
Morbius wiegt laut Internet 77 kg.
Die Hälfte des Körpergewichts
wären fast 40 Liter Blut.
Wenn du jetzt mal umrechnest ...
Das Gehirn braucht viel Energie.
Das wissen viele nicht.
Da müsste er jeden Tag
2 erwachsene Menschen leersaugen
und wahrscheinlich töten.
Also besser von ihm fernhalten!
Er versucht ja, dagegen anzukämpfen
und das Richtige zu tun.
Wie nehmt ihr Morbius wahr:
Schurke oder tragischer Antiheld?
Schreibt in die Kommentare.
Bist du hier,
um die Welt zu heilen?
Oder sie zu vernichten?
Wenn man Blut trinkt,
holt man sich doch Krankheiten rein.
Warum haben Vampir-Fledermäuse
nicht ständig Infektionen?
Es stimmt wirklich,
sie haben
ein extrem gutes Abwehrsystem.
Es gibt kaum
ein besseres Abwehrsystem.
Sie sind z.B.
gegen Retro-Viren unempfindlich.
Also HIV tut denen gar nichts,
aber auch andere Retroviren nicht.
Sie haben zudem
eigene Schutzbakterien,
die sie
gegen Erkrankungen schützen können.
Das alles haben wir Menschen nicht.
Die sind sehr gut geschützt.
Da spielt auch wieder
das spezielle Genom eine Rolle.
Das können wir
nicht von denen übernehmen.
Wir müssten alles übernehmen.
Wir müssten unsere Zellen ändern,
die Bakterien übernehmen
und das Zusammenspiel von Bakterien
und Erbsubstanz ändern.
Ein Riesending,
aber wir können ja experimentieren.
Mal schauen,
wie erfolgreich wir sind.
Aber wenn es nicht klappt
und nicht funktioniert wie im Film:
Was würde es mit uns machen,
wenn wir als Normalos Blut trinken?
Das funktioniert nicht gut.
Blut ist sehr salzig.
Man hat 4 mg Natrium,
also Kochsalz, in 100 ml Wasser.
Im Blut ist es 200-mal so viel.
Also 850 mg.
Das könnte der Grund sein,
warum normalen Menschen,
wenn sie Blut trinken,
schnell schlecht wird.
Es ist total salzig,
würde Wasser aus den Zellen ziehen.
Man würde austrocknen
und es würde einem schnell schlecht.
Blut trinken ist keine gute Idee,
wenn ihr nicht Morbius heißt.
Eine Verwandlung wie bei Morbius
rückt in weite Ferne.
Aber es gibt im realen Leben
Menschen, die Blut trinken.
Sie nennen sich Real-Life-Vampire.
Eine Kollegin unseres Team
hat 2 von ihnen getroffen.
Es hat wenig mit
den fiktionalen Vampiren zu tun.
Es sind nur gewisse Ähnlichkeiten,
die aufeinander treffen.
Wenn man es
auf den kleinsten Nenner bringt:
Wir trinken Menschenblut,
haben ein Bedürfnis danach.
Mark, du sagtest, sie gehen
nicht so gern an die Öffentlichkeit.
Wie nimmst du diese Szene wahr?
Es war schwierig, sie zu finden,
weil sie so unscheinbar sind.
Das trägt manchmal dazu bei,
dass sie sich für Vampire mit
merkwürdigen Eigenschaften halten.
Du hast aber mit ihnen geredet
und ein Buch drüber geschrieben.
Woher kommt dein Interesse?
Ich fand es spannend.
Meine Nachbarin in New York
hat eine Art Vampir-Fanclub.
So kam ich langsam dazu.
Dann hörte ich
von den Real-Life-Vampiren.
Hier in Leipzig traf ich dann
die größte Gruppe von ihnen,
die es in Europa gibt.
Du hast einen Fragebogen entwickelt,
um die Szene kennenzulernen.
Was waren
die wichtigsten Erkenntnisse?
Was macht sie zu Vampiren?
Ihre Selbstbeschreibung
ist interessant.
Das sind Lichtempfindlichkeit
und Schlafstörungen.
Alles, was man auch
bei einem Film-Vampir vermutet.
Aber auch schnelle Wundheilung.
Sie meinen,
ihre Wunden heilen schneller.
Alle sagten auch,
dass sie selber Blut trinken.
Wie haben sie das beschrieben?
Blut zu trinken
wird als Notwendigkeit beschrieben.
Die meisten fühlen sich unwohl,
wenn sie es länger nicht trinken.
Also so 2 bis 4 Wochen.
Sie werden unruhig oder wütend,
können nicht gut schlafen.
Es war auffällig,
dass das ernst ist.
In der Reportage hieß es,
dass sie Menschenblut trinken.
Ist das üblich oder
greifen sie auch mal zu Tierblut?
Überhaupt nicht.
In der Mittelalter-Szene
wird manchmal Tierblut getrunken.
In der Vampir-Szene gibt es
nur frisches, warmes Menschenblut.
Nicht eingefroren oder gemixt,
sondern so direkt wie möglich.
Du sagst, es gibt einen Leidensdruck.
Es geht ihnen nicht gut,
wenn sie das nicht trinken.
Muss man da Angst haben?
Werden die übergriffig?
Ich habe das noch nie erlebt
und auch nie davon gehört.
Einige in der Studie berichteten,
sie hätten andere
unter Vorwand verletzt,
um ans Blut zu kommen.
Ich denke, das ist absolut selten.
Es gelten auch Grundsätze,
die auch sehr auffällig sind.
Eine Art von Freundlichkeit,
wie man miteinander redet.
D.h. safe, sane and consensual.
D.h. bei gesundem Menschenverstand,
bei voller,
einvernehmlicher Aufklärung.
Anders passiert es nicht.
Es steht niemand
mit einer Axt hinter einer Brücke.
Die Menschen wollen sich auch mögen.
Es geht nicht
um zufällig blutende Menschen.
Das finden sie nicht interessant.
Wie finden sie sich gegenseitig?
Das sind soziale Netzwerke,
etwas verschlossen,
aber nicht super geheim.
Es reicht von Netzwerken
zum reinen Blutaustausch
bis zu Netzwerken,
wo sie auch noch anderes machen,
Basteln, Quatschen und so.
Wie viel Blut trinken die so?
Kann man das sagen?
Die Mengen sind meist gering,
vielleicht wie ein Schnapsglas.
Einige sahen es als Ehrensache an,
ganz viel Blut zu trinken.
Aber das
sind ganz seltene Ausnahmen.
Mit Blut
kann man Krankheiten übertragen.
Wie sind da die Regeln
oder Vorkehrungen dafür?
Es wird offen darüber gesprochen,
welche Krankheiten vorhanden sind.
Oder auch welche Vorlieben es gibt.
Das funktioniert alles
sehr ruhig und vorsichtig.
Da passiert eigentlich nichts.
Man kann es sich vorstellen
wie beim Geschlechtsverkehr.
Da muss man auch
über Geschlechtskrankheiten reden.
Die meisten
haben wahrscheinlich keine Fangzähne.
Wie kommen sie denn
an das Blut ran, praktisch?
Die Fangzähne
sind eher eine Art Schmuck.
Die dienen nicht dazu,
das Blut zu gewinnen.
Fast alle, die ich kenne,
machen es über Kanülen.
Einige schneiden auch.
Aber es soll nichts mit Schmerz
oder sexuellen Handlungen
zu tun haben.
Es geht um Blutübertragung,
Bindung und gemeinsames Erleben.
Das war es.
Das sind ja alles Selbstauskünfte.
Für uns "Normalos" ist es schwer,
sich das vorzustellen
wie es sich anfühlt, Vampir zu sein.
Kann es, provokant gefragt, sein,
dass die Leute sich das einbilden?
Es ist dieselbe Art von Einbildung,
die du hast, wenn du mit jemandem
eine Verbindung eingehen willst
Viele Menschen
haben Sehnsucht danach.
Das Blut ersetzt hier das,
was "Normalos"
durch alltägliche Handlungen machen.
Wenn du mit deinem Partner im Sand
unterm Sternenhimmel sitzt,
und mit einem leckeren Wein.
Da sind Botenstoffe
in deinem Körper,
die dich glücklich machen.
Das kann man
auch alles im Körper messen.
Ich würde es nicht
reine Einbildung nennen.
Es ist für dich persönlich
durch die Botenstoffe und den Moment
und durch Geflitter
ist es ernst und wirklich.
Was sagst du zu Leuten, die sagen,
das seien Spinner?
Es gibt ja
viele feste Überzeugungen.
Du kannst Kathedralen
aus Streichhölzern bauen
oder glauben, dass Menschen
über Wasser gehen können.
Das sind feste Überzeugungen.
Eine Gesellschaft sollte aushalten,
dass Menschen
feste Überzeugungen haben,
die für sie
ernst, wirklich und schön.
Einen lebenden Vampir
wie bei "Morbius"
wird es im echten Leben
eher nicht geben.
Unser komplettes Genom
müsste dafür verändert werden,
damit wir von Blut leben könnten.
Aber die Real-Life-Vampire
sind schon da.
Da geht es um unsere Toleranz
und Aufgeschlossenheit,
wie wir mit diesen Vampiren
unter uns leben wollen.
Ich bin ... (faucht).
Nur ein Scherz.
Ich bin Dr. Morbius.
Mark, danke.
War mir eine Freude.
Und ihr schreibt bitte,
wie ihr diese Folge fandet.
Lasst einen Kommentar da
und vergesst nicht ...
... die Glocke zu drücken.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder.
Bis dahin!
Tschüs.
Liebevolle Berührungen.
Wir sind ein Team,
das sich gut kennt.
Arbeiten seit einem Jahr zusammen.
Das ist
der echte Leipziger Südfriedhof.
Die Stadtverwaltung ist cool.
Du fandst es gruselig?
Ich habe Angst im Dunkeln.
Ich will nicht
im Dunkeln zum Auto laufen.
Es ist schwierig, dass alle
Körperzellen verändert sein sollen.
Das dürfte ...
*Glocken läuten.*
Ist doch geil.
Eigentlich ist es geil.
Copyright MDR 2022